do you know what's the most important
thing to buy on Black Friday and Cyber
Monday anything that you put money into
that feeds you back five times the
amount of money you put into meaning if
I buy TV on sale for 500 am I going to
turn that 500 into 2500 no it's actually
going to cost you money because it's
stealing time away from me to watch the
screen if I buy a new game Nintendo Xbox
whatever am I making return on my money
if the answer is no before going and
buying anything that's going to lose you
money cost you money and give you
nothing in return first invest into
yourself what new skill set do you need
to improve in in this economy is it
sales is it persuasion is it speaking is
it strategy what is it whatever it is we
have bundles going on right now with
different courses with over ten thousand
dollars of savings if you want to
recreate yourself before going and doing
what 99 of America is going to which is
going buying TV shop and Amazon all that
stuff first go buy a bundle here invest
into yourself click on the link above or
below to find out what the bundles are
I'll see there